peut maintenant
et
[Musique]
m
de la ficelle
voici nos questions
[Musique]
voilà bruno gaccio patron des guignols
sur canal alors d'abord avant de parler
de ce qui vous amène bruno gaccio quand
vous entendez ces révélations sur castro
vous agissez comme en haut je suis pas
spécialement étonné ouais on n'a jamais
pensé que c'était plus grand humaniste
de la terre mais en même temps il ya
toujours cette ambiguïté à cuba ils
savent tous lire ils savent tous écrire
c'est une espèce de culture qui traîne
et en même temps c'est un bordel immense
donc est ce que c'est vrai ça d'abord
est ce que est ce que c'est vrai qu'à
cuba
les gens sont plus éduqués que dans les
autres pays d'amérique latine
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans les années
60 de 60 à 80 il faut comprendre que
cuba est la vitrine du socialisme
mondial un dire que pour l'urss il faut
absolument que ça se passe bien puisque
c'est aux portes de l'empiré américain
donc ils sont effectivement effet du
volume sous une avalanche de de roubles
qui va leur permettre de tenir ainsi un
système scolaire et de santé getty ça
veut rien dire l'envoi une avalanche de
roulis doivent acheter une baguette ici
bas si y'a plus qu'à trois baguettes
ce qui est intéressant avec les bouquins
de raffi c'est pas tellement sur le
socialisme cubain c'est sur castres aux
lecteurs de hitler admirateur de
mussolini phalangistes à l'époque de
primo de rivera à tous les dictateurs
lisent les dictateurs et les dictateurs
la cm qui va dictateur il m'a pas lire
aristote cherche il est vrai bien alors
bruno gaccio grands soirs dans le patron
des guignols de l'info sur canal est ici
pour la sortie de [ __ ] 15 ans le
meilleur de 15 ans des guignols en vhs
et dvd
alors c'est le must absolu pour tout
dvdthèque je veux dire là d'un couple à
voir quoi moi je n'ai chauriens les ja
je veux dire franchement il ya les
maisons
4h32 programme alors il ya tout yahia
avant que vous arriviez 6 à la boîte à
coucou n'allait pas mais ça s'appelait
les arènes de l'info
enfin je vais pas vous demander ce que
vous en pensez mais j'aimais bien ouais
la boîte à coucou je tourne toujours
trouvé ça extrêmement poétique
alors il ya tapis sévèrement burné
ouais il ya eu des problèmes avec tapie
a eu des noms il aime bien il le seul
truc qui l'ont bien de tapisser qui dit
j'ai pas une taupe canton nord est là
car je suis beaucoup plus classe que
singer plus de classe ouais ouais c'est
sûr y'a papin papn cantona peintre
évidemment grand moment grands dégâts
extraordinaires sans rien les mecs qui a
dépassé sa marionnette ouais il est allé
plus loin que nous c'est vrai qu'à un
moment ça lui est la marionnette
non mais je ne sais pas si on y est pour
quelque chose mais à un moment il a dû
se regarde et il a dû se dire je peux me
lâcher je peux le faire et là il nous a
lâchés des phrases sur des sardines qui
suivait des bateaux avec des
journalistes on n'a plus rien compris et
nous on n'arrivait même plus à faire
c'est quand on écrivait disait mais non
bah non il est plus fort que nous il a
même sorti des bouquins des bouquins sur
les comptes only les crottes
qu'est ce que tu veux faire après tu es
là toi tu dis bon ben on prend la
marionnette dépassés par leurs modèles
absolument à la guerre du golfe il ya la
guerre et la guerre de l'emploi 3 on va
voir si la fois bientôt raymond barre
par raymond barre la world company c'est
ben je veux pas me vanter mais on l'a
fait avant viviane forrester quand on
m'a parlé de l'horreur économique
on a été les premiers à emmener dans un
grand média claque qui était la
télévision que les mêmes le monde
politique ne dirigeait pas le monde
bien que ceux qui dirigeaient le monde
c'était le monde économique imposé les
dirigeants ce qui maintenant est assez
communément admis mais à l'époque
effectivement c'était pas alors il ya
les voleurs de patates évidemment moi
j'étais pas donc je fais le mariage
les animateurs producteurs voleurs de
patates moi je n'étais pas dans le coup
non mais c'est parce qu'on n'avait pas
la marionnette et nous est alors la
dernière en date ben laden ils sont
issus de classes
là ça marche très très fort ben on le
fait moins ouais normal le 13 septembre
le 12 et le 13 septembre ça avait du
sens pendant quelques mois ça a eu du
sens maintenant ça n'a aucun sens et
puis sur l'espèce dû kaunas j'ai un tout
petit problème ça pose un problème c'est
que nous quand on dit les espèces dites
menace c'est ben laden qui parle c'est
vraiment la marque qui parlent et ils
parlent de leur façon de traiter les
femmes
et quand je vois des petits cons qui
traite les nanas dix pistes du kun à ce
même mois j'arrête parce que je veux pas
qu'il est violent c'est des conneries
c'est des gros contenu vous regardez
trop la télévision
ah tiens bon soir
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des clients là c'est ouais c'est
extrêmement émouvant bar est bien sûr ça
je sors jamais - donc quand je vois que
des gens nous avaient justement
justement vous sortez jamais mais alors
si vous avez en face de vous leur diriez
quoi à présent florent pagny vous diriez
quoi si vous le dis en face de vous
comme s'asseoir dans une soirée quand on
gagne son bric on peut enfiler 50 pour
que les autres vivent
ouais il reste quand même ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait tous un nom mais ça par
exemple c'est ça c'est un truc c'est un
peu chiant que je vais raconter mais les
impôts c'est le truc le plus républicain
du monde décident que un jour chacun va
donner de son plein gré une partie de ce
qu'ils gagnent au prorata de ce qu'ils
gagneraient donc c'est très républicain
et puis on invente des passe-droits des
trucs de deux sorties y en a qui
paieront moins et puis tout d'un coup ma
fille de 8 ans un jour me dit papa en
paie trop d'impôts l'état c'est un
voleur la quitte à 10 à kaunas non mais
l entente et la soeur de dire que l'état
est un voleur d'un moment payer ses
impôts ses volets n'ont payé ses impôts
c'est que les hôpitaux fonctionnent
c'est que les écoles fonctionnent c'est
que les services publics fonctionnent ou
alors on décide qu'on veut plus de ça
ouais pour ça avec la voter pour 120 g
us eric florent pagny vous aime pas
beaucoup il ya là il s'est dit je vais
me venger en faisant une chanson la
chanson s'appelle l'homme marionnettes
donc que gray c vous ayez sur alors les
paroles
ouais il a rien dans la tête il est
vraiment très bête
moi je suis d'accord jusque-là non mais
faut pas dire ça il fait il fait ce
qu'il a
alors on continue avec les gens que vous
ne rencontrait pas dans les soirées
parce que vous sortez pas banon patrick
sébastien ah oui ça faisait du mal
non j'ai du mal patrick sébastien
d'ailleurs mes potes se sont marrés ya
pas longtemps parce que je disais que
j'aimais bien l'émission de patrick
sébastien est ce qu'il serait là le plus
grand cabaret parce que ça véhicule pour
moi d des valeurs qui sont un peu plus
marrante que la star academy mais c'est
à dire qu'il ya des mecs qui ont
vraiment bossé ils font des numéros
peut-être à la con en tout cas c'est des
gens qui ont un véritable talent qui par
leur talent apporte du bonheur aux gens
est passé à la télévision c'est très
bien sinon patrick sébastien est un
[ __ ] je n'aime pas bah il dit vous
allez vite vous gaccio c'est une merde
ça ça me gêne pas bien sûr c'est une
merde ce mec c'est un gros con sans
l'ombre d'un talent ça ça me gêne pas ah
bon non c'est ce qu'il a ajouté après
sur ma famille qui me gêne à moi je suis
pas au courant non parce qu'il a ajouté
des trucs sur ma famille et ça c'est
impardonnable 1 parce que ma famille
elle n'y est pour rien que moi une
traîne pour un gros con c'est pas un
problème mais qu'il s'en prenne à ma
famille c'est pas bon vous avez des
infos que j'ai pas bien guillaume durand
si vous le rencontriez comme ça une
baffe dans la gueule
ah oui d'accord mais pas pour moi encore
pas pour moi pour ce qu'il a aussi dit
de la femme que j'aime
ouais et ce qu'il a dit de la femme que
j'aime c'est méprisant c'est sexiste
c'est ridicule et faux
il a dit vous vous serviez des guignols
en gros pour faire la carrière daniel
michaud rose c'est ça non il a surtout
dit qu'elle qu'elle avait passé trois
heures
normale sup qu'elle passait son temps à
choisir ses robes fendi alors qu'il
passait son temps à travailler pour lui
et qu'à dix minutes de l'émission il est
finalement je vais le faire tout seul je
le sens bien
ouais et que moi je récupérerai une
femme en pleurs tous les soirs donc pour
ça il aurait une tarte dans la gueule
sayah le passé je suis bernadette chirac
avec le sac c'était là un peu loin non
lorsque excuses - bernadette voilà
d'accord bon c'est bien là n'ont cessé
ces biens n'ont vraiment non mais je
vous dis ce que je pense mais voilà
c'est bien
bon ben laden si vous l'aviez en face de
vous la com ça excuse du coup nas âge le
flingue direct à est d'accord oui ça
rendrait service à pau manage leurs
flingues et georgia bouille chance à
dubaï ou qu'est ce qui lie pour qu'est
ce qui te fait rien n'est pas là parce
qu'il l'a fait exprès et ouais mais
c'est pas lui qui est fait
[Applaudissements]
alors quelqu'un qui est pas là ce soir
mais si vous rencontriez qu'est ce que
vous lui diriez laurent baffie ben je
lui dirai ma fille pourquoi tu me parles
plus bas et vous en veulent à vraiment
bah ouais mais c'est sa cause de la
piscine à mon avis non c'est pas ça je
crois que c'est plus profond que ça chez
lui je connais non je laime moi c'est
quelqu'un qui me fait marrer ici il fait
la mecque qui me fait vraiment marrer
c'est un des rares qui me fait rire et
il ya eu un malentendu parce que quand
il a eu sa marionnette avant même
qu'elles sortent ces adolescentes yann
salle de bain et avant même que la
marionnette soit apparue à la télé ne
parlait plus oui parce que non mais
après mais bah tu sais ce que c'est que
tu commences à rire sur un truc
le truc prend puis tu sais plus tard été
et puis on en a fait un peu trop voilà
on en arrête de trop et c'est bien ça
lui fera plaisir
non mais c'est vrai je le pense pourrait
lui dire mais comme il peut pas me
parler alors il veut pas vous rencontrez
entendu il vient pas du tout non il n'ya
pas vraiment il m'a dit ah gaccio n'a
pas su agir et voir ton film même si
c'est une merde
[Applaudissements]
alors les guignols tout a commencé en
1988 quand alain de greef veut remplacer
les nuls et décide d'adapter un show
anglais de marionnettes qui s'appelle le
site beating images ça devient les
arènes de l'info
en 1990 elle devient les guignols vous
vous arrivez en 1992 donc pas au début
c'est mon quatre heures après le début
mais malgré tous les changements dans
l'équipe qui a pu avoir vous êtes
toujours là voix bah ouais je voudrais
ce fait parce que c'est je veux dire une
bêtise bête est bête
ouais c'est vraiment le métier que
j'aime faire et je savais pas qu'il
existait et c'est mon moyen d'expression
à moi il ya des gens qui aiment le
cinéma qui aiment la radio le théâtre
moi c'est mon moyen d'expression je peux
y faire du théâtre puis ce canal théâtre
de marionnettes c'est une somme
ça c'est un truc pour les guignols qui
aiment que je trouve extrêmement
émouvant encore c'est des gens qui
fabrique des marionnettes à la main il
ya des manipulateurs de donc sont des
intermittents du spectacle il ya des
voix il ya des maquilleuses yade est
habillée des réalisateurs dont celui de
cette émission
tous ces petits métiers fabrique tous
les jours pendant dix minutes une vraie
émission dérivée
c'est quand même un vrai travail qui
fait travailler à 200 fiches de paye
pour moi c'est un gros boulot et c'est
déjà si en plus ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire tous ils aiment ce qu'ils font
et moi j'adore faire ce que je fais
alors quand on habite en a pas marre non
j'aimerais y en a pas de raison d'un
mariage m
il ya quand même des gens qui regardent
les guignols tous les soirs ça va dans
les soirs bas de 2 millions 7 à les
soirs au comme là on est en ce moment à
trois millions cinq as énorme avec des
pointes à 4 millions deux jours on a 17
d'or mais les mecs se marque saisissez
pas pour nous pourquoi on a donné à ces
deux ans à ses camarades
alors ça vous fait quoi aujourd'hui de
bosser entre emmanuelle chat et stéphane
bern
la vie change ouais nazis change n'y a
pas de contacts c'est une des choses qui
les plus désagréables aujourd'hui c'est
que avant il y avait un contact alors
c'était toujours mieux avant on s'en
fout mais avant il y avait un contact
une continuité qui faisait que c'était
il y avait une homogénéité à cette
chaîne
mais non il y en a plus il y à chaque
fois son émission dans son coin berne
qui enregistre la sienne nous qui
faisons un autre en direct mais à midi
font la leur on se rencontre pas et puis
voilà au bout d'un an
on sent bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui
se délite on ne peut pas être solidaire
a pour que tout le monde a quitté canal
à part vous et philippe dana ça c'est
pas gentil
bah moi parce que j'aime ça donne parce
qu'il peut pas ça c'est pas gentil non
plus alors vous avez déjà été censuré
par la direction mais eux la nouvelle
direction la ouais ouais ouais
sur quoi sur un sketch
qui parlait de canal+ était l'arrivée 2
de stéphane bern à canal ouais et il
trouvait avec l'ambiance qu'on avait mis
autour de ça était un peu trop militaire
ouais donc il en dit on passe pas le
sketch il ya eu réunion j'ai dit voilà
moi c'est toujours pareil
vous êtes le patron c'est vous qui
décidez ce qui passe à l'antenne et
j'accepte la censure si elle est trois
fois par semaine je prends mes
responsabilités si elle est une fois par
an on discute la lescure lescure nous a
sans cesse situation de greffe aussi la
graphologie d'aller trop loin
bien sûr toutes les directions de noah
n'ont pas pour le moment ce que vous
dites c'est que c'est pas ça va à ses
supporters c'est très supportable y
avait bien sûr
alors on parle un petit peu de vous
maintenant bruno gaccio parce qu'on
reconnaît les guignols - vous connais
moins vous êtes né en 1958 par an
prolétaires ah ouais ouais c'est à dire
c'est à dire papa maçon mais pas
d'entrepreneurs formation n'a sipartech
on la capsule à l'aller sur les murs et
puis voilà c'est un [ __ ] ma mère est
pas peu fiers ils sont tous les deux à
la retraite je crois qu'il gagne en ce
moment aux alentours de 7 mille balles
par mois la retraite 2 à 2 à baa2 ils
ont travaillé mon père a cotisé quarante
sept ans si vous pouviez lâcher un peu
de thunes pour papa ça sylvain harvey
akelarre facile von harnack donc en face
à saint-etienne l'adolescence vous fait
les 400 coups vous êtes parfaite
autodidacte on peut dire ouais vous
fuyez le lycée à l'âge de 15 ans vous
raté pour aime le faire pour hâter un c
ap typographe non ah bon non j'arrête
avant un je peux regarder des chèvres
oui c'est ça oui chevry en ardèche
ouais c'est xavier nos barbe et les
cheveux jusque là non non non c'était
vachement plus rigolo que ça c'est
vachement plus rigolo que ça c'était on
est partis avec
un copain à bordeaux dans la drôme et on
a gardé des chèvres voilà on s'est
occupé de chèvre avec 87 elle était très
bien on a gagné le prix du picodon
drôme-ardèche roll avec monsieur tron il
s'appelait c'est un connard nous à la
maison la whey non mais c'est vrai j'ai
fait ça pendant un an et demi c'est un
camion est d'accord et alors tout va
bien ah ouais j'adorais ça mais c'est
marrant comme boulot quand même pas
pensé à ça tu vois quand été proclamée
j'ai gardé des moutons alors toi aussi
ça s'appelle des élèves ça s'appelle des
élèves m déception non j'ai gardé des
boutons des vrais moutons vrai mais
ouais ouais ouais
l'arrêté petit mail à foot on ne
découvre pas du tout obligé de faire le
bruit il compresse pardon j'ai raté j'ai
raté mes années soixante dix je suis
content j'ai perdu plein de trucs alors
donc à l'âge de 20 ans bruno vous arrivé
à paris en 1983 vont rentrer petit cadre
de bouvard et puis vous commencé à
écrire des sketches dont le fameux
trisomique de timsit qui lui a valu
tellement de malheurs à ce pauvre timsit
ans gars 1
vous regrettez ça bah non non c'est un
personnage odieux qu'il y ait des choses
au dialogue
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'y fasse
justement j'ai pas écrire un personnage
sûr c'était pas un trisomique c'est un
garagiste way qui disait tout bêtement
que bon vin chez les trisomiques c'est
comme les crevettes roses à part la tête
tout est bon c'est pas la balle n'a plus
classe du monde mais en fait un café
pendant un an au spectacle il a sorti la
cassette
ça a duré rennes on l'a vendu le
spectacle passe sur france 2 les mecs
vois ça hop faut interdire la cassette
ouais ouais mais on a déjà vendu la
casse est sacrément et demi qu'elle en
vente bien alors ce plan personnel bruno
gaccio je crois que le plus simple pour
savoir comment s'est passé votre vie
privée
c'est d'aller voir le démon de midi
michèle bernier qui racontent des scènes
de votre vie conjugale puisque michel
après quelques années passées avec bruno
gaccio
on a fait une pièce qui a beaucoup de
français c'est une adaptation d'une
bande dessinée de florence cestac ses
serres vous vous reconnaissez pas du
tout je me reconnais et vous allez vous
reconnaître aussi
mais c'est un spectacle que j'ai
beaucoup aimée parce que une rupture
c'est toujours difficile et c'est un
spectacle qui l'a un peu guéri et pour
la première fois elle a joué la comédie
en étant d'une énorme sincérité et quand
je suis allé la voir sans lui dire j'ai
vu la salle se levait et j'ai été émue
pour elle c'était très bien
et puis en nuit d'ivresse et d'excès
dans tôt si moi je craigne j'enlèverai
la robe rouge mais bon sinon elle est
raide d'actes michel si nous regardent
comme des hôtes alors sur le plan
financier vous devez être très riche non
non non je gagne très bien ma vie je
suis à l'aise mais je suis pas riche
dont bruno tu que je te dise combien je
gagne le wef est ridicule dans seize
mille euros par mois + ses droits
d'auteur fait quoi cent mille balles ça
non ça fait un peu plus de son médecin
vous n'avez pas trop perdu quand
l'action vivement d'universel s'est
écroulé j'ai donné mon slip mes
chaussettes gpu abbaoui faut dire la
vérité vous avez investi comme vous qui
faites la world company vous êtes
investi votre pognon c'est une aura pas
remettre doucement
ils m'ont fait l'amitié de me filer des
stock-options gérér donc j'ai écrit une
lettre à lescure un jour du bilan le
vieil anar que je suis recevant des
stock options ça me fait bien marrer moi
et je vais les garder quand même je me
suis renseigné on m'a dit les stock
options tant n'occupera tu prends tu
mets dans un tiroir si ça marche un jour
tu les ressorts et à de l'argent j'ai
dit on fait comme ça et puis j'avais
confiance moi danser la maison j'en ai
acheté un petit peu mais pas trop
j'espère un peu trop un peu trop abusif
et nick est là parce qu'il ya un article
que j'adore dans le succès dans new york
times nous expliquent qu'ils ont été
ruinés en bourse et moi je trouve ça
extraordinaire de voir caudry avant dans
le jeu partait de l'idée à quelqu'un
d'abord ça veut dire que j'ai écrit un
article dans le new york times déjà ça
serait serré et étape non mais c'est
très bon joueur
bien que qui le demandent
non mais mais c'est bah oui je partais
de l'idée que qu'un type qui achètent
des actions pense toujours faire un
profit me fait moins profit il fait un
pourboire
celui qui fait le profit c'est celui qui
possède le million d'actions cesser les
dirigeants qui font des profits et il
joue avec les petits actionnaires c'est
juste ça qu'il faut comprendre la bourse
est pas la roulette c'est une roulette
ou c'est toujours mieux numéro qui sort
vous avez compris ça maintenant mais
j'avais compris à long terme est
d'accord mais le dernier truc qui vous
restez quand même du capitalisme ça y
est là c'est fini mais c'est pas le
capitalisme c'est le capitalisme bien
fait ouais moi je pense je suis un
imbécile qui pense que tous les systèmes
fonctionnent on parler de cuba tout à
l'heure moi je pense que le système
communisme communiste ça peut
fonctionner pourquoi ça ne
fonctionnerait pas chacun fabrique pour
l'état l'état redistribue à chacun selon
ses besoins
pourquoi pas sauf que quand ça arrive en
hausse et des êtres humains qui en
gardent tout bon bain après on bikes
rêve
et voilà le système capitaliste c'est la
même chose si c'est un mec fabriquent
ils vont un produit bon ben on dit très
bien
il vend son produit tout le monde achète
le produit les gens qui fabriquent le
produire les pays bien tout va bien tout
le monde gagne de l'argent
le système fonctionne sauf que quand ça
arrive aux patrons et y regardent et
puis là on va aux ouvriers cette
nouvelle par mois pour mon père quand il
à la retraite et votre jeunesse ouais ma
mère aussi eu donc il ya un truc qui
fonctionne pas c'est tout dites moi vous
allez continuer comme ça longtemps sur
canal pour récupérer le pognon que
j'avais perdu en bourse non à bala il
faudrait qu'ils aillent vraiment jusqu'à
la retraite
ça vous manque pas parce que quand on
vous présente la bruno gaccio le patron
des guignols tout le monde applaudit
j'aimerais être de formidables mais
voilà mais c'est simplement pas de
mettre une star comme ceux que vous
allumez tous les soirs lutter non alors
j'ai deux problèmes avec ça vous avez
dit que j'avais fait le théâtre de
bouvard
donc je montrerai ma tête à la tv à
l'époque il y avait 15 ou 16 millions de
personnes qui regardaient tous les soirs
c'est vrai qu'il y avait trois chaînes à
l'époque les gars c'est quand même mieux
et il y avait 15 millions de personnes
et dans la rue les gens me taper dans le
dos je vous aiguille en sort vous êtes
qu'on a refusé de cours non monsieur je
suis pas content
con je tenais je suis pas con konaré au
bout d'un moment je ne sais pas gérer ça
je gère très mal le côté familier et
donc le mon ego est complètement flatté
par les guignols puisque c'est mon
travail qui reconnut et j'adore ça et de
temps en temps j'ai reçus par thierry
ardisson et je me mets dans ma tête et
ça va c'est pas trop mal bon voilà je
sais que demain matin quand j'irai
chercher mon pain on me dira je vous ai
vu hier fallait pas dire qu'on a la télé
vous aurez à vivre vous aurez le
meilleur pain de la boulangerie
ouais alors le plus gros dommage
collatéral des guignols pour moi en tous
les cas c'est c'est guillaume durand on
s'est vraiment fait ils tuent et enfin
c'est ce qu'il dit dans son livre est
vraiment poussé vraiment n'est pas
obligé de le croire
ouais ouais bon la rue alors il a fait
un beau cas chez grasset qui s'appelle
la peur bleue il dénonce votre racisme
social et vie voilà gaccio ccc un fils
de prolo il déteste les riches la
moindre cravate le moindre soupçon mèche
on est vomi socialement et un
vomissement sociales exprimées par des
types qui gagnent des fortunes en plus
dire que il vous reproche finalement
vous le prendre le voir attaquer parce
que c'est un fils de bourgeois
mais en fait de gagner beaucoup plus de
pognon que les bourgeois c'est du pur
fantasme
c'est de la susceptibilité blessé d'un
type qui a raté un truc qui cherche un
responsable il a pensé que de greffe et
moins on voulait le dégommer c'est
absolument ridicule
je ne sais pas il ya rien à répondre à
ça c'est un truc ridicule
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
allez les clients à prendre alors je
vous demande de vous arrêter
alors bruno gaccio on vous présente plus
et c'est bien dommage d'être dans cette
émission tous les quinze jours donc on
va arrêter de vous présenter à chaque
fois pas seulement tous les quinze jours
je sais pas lionel dutemple alors vous
on se présente à lionel dutemple j'ai 36
ans je travaille air france ouais
13 vous êtes pilote d'avion non chef
avion c'est moi qui dirige les a vus à
la carte rien ça plane pour vous quoi
exactement
très bien ahmed hamidi vous vous
présentez soir ahmed hamidi 33 ans
j'aime les parents je suis pour l'entrée
de la turquie en europe
bruno gaccio il ya deux semaines
vous étiez là pour le guignol et le
magistrat vous revenez aujourd'hui pour
l'année des guignols le dvd en deux
semaines vous avez fait comme une
émission de télé boillon 2 haïti tout
ouais j'ai fait ardisson et pascale
clark en aparté parce que c'est une très
très bonne émission qui n'est pas
fatigant d'affaires en même temps un
vous avez vendu combien de livres
la tentation c'est de répondre je suis
pas libre et c'est pas moi qui les vend
les lignes j'ai entendu parler de ces
deux bouquins peu près à peu près à peu
près vous est pris combien de petits des
géants tels cost pour parler avec des
journalistes
j'ai pas pris tous les petits déjeuners
des fois je suis parti au mieux de la
nuit d'accor en deux semaines vous avez
fait l'amour combien de fois zéro mort
l'amour j'ai fait l'amour 0 froid du
nord bah si ça veut pas dire que j'en ai
paniqué un paquet
alors d'accord je vous ai manqué ah
ouais
[Musique]
alors le dvd l'année des guignols un
jean-pierre ça peut tout faire
donc c'est l'utilisation de jean pierre
raffarin sur la couverture du dvd c'est
une contrebasse vous l'utilisez pour
faire des phares des phares à vente de
chevaux
bien que chirac qui s'en sert comme
premier ministre finalement il peut
servir à plein d'autres trucs ce mec là
vous diriez quoi pour qu'on l'achète le
dvd acheté le sinon on est viré
ouais et comme ça je pourrais faire
l'amour au moins deux fois par semaine
j'ai remarqué en relisant toutes vos
interviews pour préparer cette émission
que vous posez toujours les mêmes
questions
alors je vais faire pareil on va les
faire une fois pour toute et ça sera la
dernière fois que vous y répondre est
d'accord le problème c'est que vous avez
30 secondes maximum pour répondre serge
tu prends des tops à 30 secondes une
coupe quand on a un peu ton tout pensé
top oui non ce n'est les outils pour
penser oui mais buta remake argumenté un
peu invité toutes les deux semaines chez
redit son attention
doit-on tout dire top oui non j'ai
l'impression quand un petit numéro de
cirque alors pareil alors moi je suis
méfiant dans les guignols donc si on a
les outils et qu'il en reste un petit
peu de ces outils qu'on tourne à penser
et ben oui on peut tout dire mais il
faut pouvoir articuler sa pensée et
c'est comme ça tous les jours
j'étais vachement d'une réponse j'ai une
valve marrante oui mais tu comprends si
jamais tu vois c'est insupportable donc
doit on tout dire tu pense que oui toi
ouais je pense qu'on peut tu penses que
gollnisch avait raison ah ah ouais mais
la joie une autre question les questions
c'est une autre question
vas-y tu penses que gollnisch a eu
raison de dire ce qu'elle est je pense
pas qu'il a raison de dire ce qu'il a
dit je pense qu'il a le droit de le dire
pour peu qu'on puisse à la fois le
critiquer a porté un matériel critique
suffisante pour les gens qui ne pourrait
de son avis et c'est là c'est simple
c'est ça la liberté d'expression c'est
de pouvoir laisser s'exprimer les gens
avec qui on n'est absolument pas
d'accord encore faut-il pouvoir les
contredire dans un dans un cadre
alors pour prier voilà encore du temps
mais dis moi et guti l'yonne la le
commissaire européen qui dit que
finalement l'homosexualité c'est un
péché que les enfants ont besoin d'une
maman et tout ça il a le droit de le
dire mais lui c'est un italien il a tous
les droits
[Applaudissements]
à la question la preuve qu'on est là
plus passe partout
est-ce que l'humour est forcément drôle
top
si c'est moi qui fait des vannes non moi
je veux répondre oui oui la preuve que
non c'est vous apporte encore la preuve
alors je vous souhaite chiant il en
reste est ce que est ce que bruno gaccio
et le site vous touchez dessin top oui
non
[Musique]
non passer quelques coups de fil mais ce
temps là on tombe sur le répondeur
interview répondeur bonjour bonjour vous
êtes bien chez pierre lescure je vais
bien merci
je bosse sur la 5e et j'ai vendu tous
mes meubles laissez moi un message bip
j'ai vu ce que tu fais sur la cinquième
c'est pas mal qui devrait prendre une
chaîne de télé oui bonjour vous êtes
bien chez monsieur madame gaccio oui on
est les parents les désoler laissé un
message ben tu t'appelles demain je te
jure
bonjour vous êtes bien chez michèle
bernier si vous n'êtes pas bruno gaccio
laissé un message bip
je ne suis pas bruno gaccio moi je suis
bruno gaccio g comment vont les enfants
michel bonjour vous êtes bien chez
florent pagny vous pouvez me laisser un
message
mais vous n'aurez pas ma liberté de
pensée bip moi je dirais excuses -
laurent florent excuses je me suis gouré
alors je sais j'ai fait un faux numéro
je voulais appeler quelqu'un d'autre en
fait je l'appellerai bonjour vous êtes
bien chez le procureur philippe bilger
je suis parti faire le guignol à la télé
avec bruno gaccio laissez moi un message
bip est plus drôle que bruno gaccio
bonjour c'est bien c'est jacques et
bernadette chirac si vous avez des
pièces jaunes laissez nous un message
bip jeudi alors en fait en vrai en vrai
vous vivez ensemble donc ouais
bonjour vous êtes bien chez patrick
sébastien je me suis fait une tête de
répondeur c'est génial pour laisser un
message bip continue à faire des
émissions de service public c'était
juste pour dire ça que je t'appelais et
je dirais j'aime bien les saltimbanques
les billets seront en vente et oui
bonjour vous êtes bien c'est jean marie
le pen je voulais sortir avec ma fille
laissez moi un message b jean-marie je
voudrais bien sortir avec ta fille puis
j'aurais bien que tu sortes avec ta
fille que tu sors du pays avec ta fille
que tu sais bonjour bonjour vous êtes
bien chez guillaume durand [ __ ] je
bosse comme un fou
laissez moi un message de pardon tu
bosse comme un fou ouais j'avais une
erreur bonjour c'est bien c'est laurent
baffie si vous avez vu mon fils laissez
moi un message bip
j'ai pas vu ton filmeront mais je veux
j'attends qu'il sorte en dvd ouais c'est
bientôt en plus laurence et gaccio
arrête de faire la gueule
un bonjour j'ai bien chez lionel jospin
je vais revenir laissez-moi message du
maire revient lionel revient ah ouais
bah oui tu me kiffe abuse au long du jeu
quoi non peut-être un autre et qui il va
rien comprendre le message bonjour vous
êtes bien c'est george boole je sais que
c'est incroyable laissez moi un message
bip laisse gagner qui arrive alors je
t'attends pas à l'aise gagné kerry on te
dit je laisse gagner kerry ouais georges
laisse gagner qu'elle est oui bah oui
maintenant vers la vie du monde en
dépend jeu c'est vrai c'est vrai oui non
c'est pourquoi on s'intéresse à la aux
élections à mes racines allemandes sont
mono
bonjour vous êtes bien chez
l'association des personnes de petite
taille de france si vous n'êtes pas trop
grand laissez-moi message bip pour à m
je vous dis qu'au basket
dac bonjour j'ai bien chez elvis presley
laissez moi un message on sait jamais
bip
quand est ce que tu fais un disque
revient revient vite ils sont tous
devenus fous ils ont laissé leur plein
dans la panique
jamais
miolles j'accueille bruno gaccio
[Musique]
un gâchis incorrigible baffie il fait ça
tout le monde l'a dit comme ça les gens
comme une demi heure ils cherchent qui
vont s'asseoir et parce qu'un rappelons
que les gens sont cons alors bruno les
guignols sont très en forme en ce moment
merci dire que l'actualité est créé un
bon scénario quand même pour les
guignols avant de rire d'une info on la
subit qu'on aimerait est là quand et
tous les jours dans un bureau où on est
quatre îles et on parle de l'actualité
et tous les jours on parle de racisme on
parle on cite sarkozy tous les jours
au bout d'un moment dans la humain on
s'est dit ah trop de mou donc faut
arrêter on fait trois minutes de silence
et on essaie mercredi c'est encore ça
c'est pas le meilleur mais c'est vrai
que je dis pas ça pour être désagréable
mais il y avait longtemps que les
guignols avait pas été dans le ton monte
earth achevé mais les guignols non c'est
pas vrai du tout alors comment sais tu
pas que jamais aimé les guignols j'ai
aimé les gars quand il était drôle et je
suis client je suis demandeur pour les
guignols me fasse rire et là tu penses
que nouveaux rôles en tout cas juste en
tout cas elle entend que j'ai vu dsk de
je me dis [ __ ] là c'est bien la toile
merci loin même si la qualité peut tenir
c'est vrai que ça va pas pleurer pendant
huit dix corps et un gros passage à vide
je viens de revenir c'est pour ça alors
bruno les hasards du calendrier font que
vous participez à un livre collectif
édité par unicef qui s'appelle fais moi
ta déclaration
lesdits droits de l'enfant dans lequel
sous la houlette de tristane banon dix
auteurs ont écrit une nouvelle sur les
droits de l'enfant
il ya d'anne frank qui avait tablé
cassis que nous recevrons tout à l'heure
il ya vincent ravalec à bernard werber
et vous voilà alors vous votre nouvelle
c'est le droit d'être protégé contre
l'exploitation mais alors je fais le
pitch de la nouvelle de bruno ses six
enfants obèses qui décide de se révolter
contre l'industrie agroalimentaire et
quitte nappe le pdg d'une boîte qui fait
des crêpes surgelés à la confiture de
fraise et il lui met une fessée cul nu
devant les télés du monde entier
ouais télé mondiale un fait c'est
mondiale [ __ ] de grosse fessée
mondiale parce que c'est tout ce qu'ils
méritent ces mecs là c'est la première
fois que j'ai eu envie de mettre une
fessée à un type c'est je sais plus si
c'est pinault arnault ils sont toujours
les deux je les confonds tout le temps
il y en a un qui avait eu il y avait 40
2 millions de francs à l'époque de sur
son compte en banque il avait demandé un
crédit à sa banque pour de 42 millions
pour éviter de payer l'impôt sur la
fortune
ouais et je m'étais dit c'est vraiment
c'est écoeurant quoi et qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire lui mettre une fessée il ya
que ça tu henry lui mettre une fessée
salles prévue plaît le banquier stern
savez plaisait les faits c'est même toit
ce temps jean charest comme temps
avec deux raquettes de ping pong il aime
bien ça leurs tarifs et indiqué publié
pour l'anniversaire de la déclaration
des droits de l'enfant le 20 novembre
c'est la journée mondiale de l'enfance
et c'est l'occasion pour l'unicef de
mobiliser pour les enfants contre le
sida
il ya un enfant qui meurt du sida dans
le monde toutes les minutes
ouais mais surtout ce qui est ce qui est
assez atroce et qui montre encore une
fois on va l'espèce de d'égoïsme de
l'occident on va dire bêtement c'est que
chez nous par exemple les transmission
mère-enfant du sida des femmes enceintes
il y en a plus voilà on a réussi à
régler ce problème là et en afrique il y
en a une toutes les 15 secondes
mais comme nous le problème est réglé on
s'occupe plus de rien il a plu crédit à
plus de recherche a plus que dalle et il
faudrait juste rappeler aux gens quand
même que les petits enfants même s'ils
sont un peu noir c'est des êtres humains
se mêler mais qui sont en train de
mourir
moi j'ai jamais rien fait de dans
l'humanitaire parce qu'elle est juste on
me demandait rien alors quand on
demandait rien savate et planque était
tranquille le jour où on me demande si
toi qui n'ont pas vraiment pour un
[ __ ] quand même alors ce qu'il faut
dire à nos amis des millions tu as des
clients que je salue ici donc l'unicef
c'est la première organisation du monde
consacré aux enfants
elle est présente dans 157 pays et elle
est uniquement financée par les dons
volontaires voilà
[Musique]